Donald Trump's disastrous trade war is
scaling up even more I've told you many
times at this point that there's not
going to be a quick sort of off-ramp
from this trade war of escalating
tariffs and in fact we seem to be
building it even bigger Donald Trump is
adding another 10% tariff later this
month to another two hundred billion
dollars in Chinese goods that will
increase to 25% by next year this is
obviously an additional an additional
tariff above and beyond those earlier
tariffs and penalties that we've been
talking about over the last several
months and in total about half of all
the products that China sells to the
United States are going to be hit by
tariffs and what this is going to do at
a broader sort of economic level is it's
going to make as designed Chinese
manufactured products which Americans
buy a ton of like it or not we do way
more expensive and it's going to make it
so that many Americans will no longer be
able to afford the stuff that they would
like to be buying
so what's China going to do in response
to these tariffs well they've already
announced what they're going to do
they're going to retaliate we don't know
exactly what and how but they've said
they will be matching the tariffs that
the United States is additionally
imposing at this point the impact of
China retaliating will be that
american-made products will be more
expensive to Chinese individuals which
is going to make them buy less of the
stuff which is going to hurt the
American businesses that American
employees work at so the sum total of
the tariffs on China and the tariffs
from China will be that workers in the
United States will have number-one less
money with which to buy number-two stuff
that's going to be more expensive not
exactly winning economic policy and this
trade war is having a monumental impact
on American farmers I've talked to you
about the impact specifically on the
manufacturing sector and on the farming
sector there's an entity called farm aid
they get calls from farmers
sometimes farmers need help signing up
for a federal program for example more
and more under Trump's tariffs the calls
to farm aid are about desperate farmers
hoping to figure out how they can keep
their businesses alive for suicidal
farmers per month are calling Farm Aid
and they're also getting calls about how
to file for bankruptcy calls about their
electricity being turned off and the
advocates that take the calls are
explaining to media outlets that talk to
them that this is the most desperate
that they've seen farmers in a very long
time and sadly it's probably going to
get worse and this this actually in
truth I have no interest in hiding from
you that this is bigger than just
Trump's tariffs Trump's agriculture
tariffs are doing way more damage than
the 12 billion Trump has allocated in
Farm Aid but beyond that dairy has been
struggling for years it's important to
understand that price volatility has
been really really destructive for the
small farms commodity prices have been
deep decreasing over the long term so
that it's been bad for fur the dairy
industry for example for a while but
these tariffs are making it much much
worse and if there's any potential good
here the only thing I can think of is
that maybe voters affected by the
tariffs are realizing that they need to
vote for something else in November we
did a story last week about polling
showing that the democratic edge going
into the midterms has grown and it's
grown disproportionately because of
Midwestern voters who presumably are
directly affected by the Trump tariffs
will it be enough to hand democrats the
senate and the house it's it's not clear
but everybody needs to go and vote
because the the trade war is not
winnable so you need to get rid of the
people that are waging it full stop